bonjour louis maugée bonjour maurizio le
temps est bon joue également à tous les
auditeurs de radio membre de la
commission exécutive de la cgt mines
centrales syndicales qui rentre dans
tout un ensemble de commémorations
autour des 80 ans du mouvement cégétiste
petit moment d'histoire louis maugée
rappelle l'union des syndicats cgt a été
créée en octobre 1936 le 25 et plus
exactement le contexte de l'époque c'est
quoi alors le contexte de l'époque
il faut remonter à beaucoup plus loin
que cette année là pour comprendre
quelle a été l'évolution du mouvement
social pour aboutir justement à cette
organisation de la cij était alors déjà
la cgt en france a été créée en 1995 ou
belles années parce que c'est
précisément le résultat d'un contexte de
montée de lutte de mécontentement
ensuite on va connaître ici en
martinique approté de 1900 l'année 1900
c'est l'année où les premiers
socialistes antillais reviennent de
france c'est le cas de lagausie hier et
ça va donner les sens justement à
l'impulsion d'un mouvement social qui va
prendre une licence à ce moment là
tailler les socialistes les premiers
socialistes antillais vont venir avec
son idée que la classe ouvrière doit
s'organiser unis des scientifiques
puisque les mouvements de grève ont eu
lieu après 10 58 l'abolition des stages
on la connaît le girly du sud est puis a
eu des nombreuses grèves ce livre sur
les exploitations agricoles mais une
organisation scientifique
ce sera l'idée des premiers socialistes
et puis à l'autre événement va se
produire
l'événement qui va se produire ce sera
en 1919 en 1919 e jules monnerot qu'ils
étaient socialistes compagnie de
lagausie re va nous quitter il va le
quitter pourquoi parce que les
socialistes la halle ils vont créer une
fraction disant que les anciens
événements de la première guerre
mondiale et ils vont dire mais ces types
là ils ont trahi le mouvement socialiste
is ont trahi nos idées donc on va faire
autre chose et c'est à ce moment là que
jules monnerot va être à l'initiative de
la création du journal justice dont le
secrétaire dans le rédacteur en ciel
sera andré aliker à l'époque être
cégétiste ça veut dire on va rappeler
quand même hein le contexte encore de
2009 136 kg a beaucoup de femmes qui
monte au créneau
notamment ces fameuses charbonnier
harbonnières les charbonnières en effet
il y a
dans l'époque où j'ai dit la grande
gamme de 1900 qui a commencé à 7 marica
qui se termine au fond soit avec une
dizaine de morts laissés sous le chaos
il ya eu de nombreuses grèves que ce
soit sept maris ou carbet lee grève
d'ouvriers à col.red martien bassillac
et puis les charbonnières effectivement
c est la première organisation syndicale
qui fut créé puisque d'ailleurs nous
allons le commémorer avec l'arrivée
d'ado venue de philippe martinez
nous allons danser la secrétaire
générale de la saucisse si j'étais
france
nous allons déposer une plaque
commémorative justement à la route du
gouvernement
la petite ruelle des terres sainville ou
été créée justement l'organisation
syndicale l'union départementale cgt qui
était là le local justement des
charbonnières alors c'est vrai que ce
sera très difficile pour nous deux de
revisiter 80 annie d'histoire cégétiste
on va rappeler quand même peut-être pour
ceux qui nous regardent par vidéo ce
petit document édité par la cgtm le
mouvement cégétiste à la martinique avec
walter guitteaud élire araujo à sa
rédaction
mais les grands combattu été mené et on
peut par exemple évoqué tout simplement
quelque chose que tout le monde connaît
qui semble être rentré dans le quotidien
qui rentrait dans le quotidien
c'est l'application tout simplement des
lois de la caisse générale de sécurité
sociale c'est une véritable révolution
en martinique à la fin des années 40
oui alors bien entendu on ne peut pas
faire l'impasse sur 36 puisque 36 et le
conte populaire c'est important de
prendre 36 pourquoi parce que 36 c'est
l'année de la création des congés payés
c'est la création du sud est conscient
collectif ce qu'on appelait les contrats
collectifs
si les 40 heures et ce qui est
particulier c'est qu'il faut se souvenir
que le front populaire ne dure qu'une
année une seule année en une seule année
un gouvernement sous l'impulsion des
grèves sous l'impulsion des
mobilisations ouvrières sur l'impulsion
des occupations d usines
d'après nos gouvernements sont
communistes à la direction d'un point de
100 ministres communistes d'apprendre
cette décision de donner satisfaction
immédiatement au monde ouvrier
ben pourquoi encore une fois on est au
sortir de la guerre d'accord on est dans
une crise économique majeure
la crise de 29 parce que la cuisse
devait tu me fais également à des
répercussions
la crise de 29 à 10 centimes en série
les parties d'abord des états unis
partie des états unis il y aura des
répercussions des mouvements trinidad
dans l'indiana en martinique bien
entendu il y aura une mobilisation et
une prise de conscience ça va déclencher
une prise de conscience considérable
alors nous sommes à la fin de la guerre
et de la deuxième guerre mondiale il ya
cette envie d'égalité avec la france et
lorsqu'on parlait de cette sécurité
sociale en parler tout simplement
d'utopie ce n'est pas possible qu'on
verse des retraites n'est pas possible
qu'on ait la même chose ici à
fort-de-france les mêmes choses que là
bas à paris alors absolument
alors il faut quand même dire c'était un
peu cie aussi de la chose à l'époque 36
et un maire apprend de prendre ce qu'ils
appellent victor sévère du ton sévère
lorsque les lois de 36 ont été avancées
ont été votés puis ton sévère pose le
problème de leur applicabilité en
martinique en guadeloupe
c'était son rôle de député en 36 dans le
cadre du front populaire et c'est
important de le signaler
et puis après précisément il faudra
attendre 47
pourquoi parce que ces lois là n'étant
pas applicables nous n'étions pas
département nous n'étions pas
directement concernés dont ils firent
fallu que précisément cette fameuse loi
d'assimilation qui permit
l'applicabilité des droits immédiatement
mais le fait que les droits et été
décidé comme étant applicable n'a pas
suffi alors parce qu'une loi est une loi
mais il faut des décrets d'application
et on va se battre igor vraie volonté
politique très politique de main tendue
de les faire baisser
et ce n'est pas évident à ce moment là
c'est pas évident du tout parce que
jusqu'à aux années 50 il y en a eu
par exemple la chasse 1 à l'achat sein
des travailleurs sont mois on va tirer
sur des travailleurs parce que
précisément ils demandaient
l'application des lois concernant la
sécurité sociale
il faut se souvenir encore les plus
anciens s'en souviennent que il ya des
fonds qui avaient été créées concerne
les allocations familiales qu'on appela
le faso le faso c'est un fonds
conduisait quittait alimenté par des
fonds des allocations familiales et 17
ont à l'époque que les femmes d'anti
nicaise ne savait pas gérer
elle pouvait pas confondre vitesse et
précipitation
donc il fallait les infantiliser en
quelque part et j'irai à leur place on a
passé très très vite sur l'importance du
secteur agricole dans les années 50 25
mille ouvriers agricoles son cas ce
salarié de moins de cent mille personnes
en martinique ce secteur agricole qui a
provoqué d'effet quand même où
retentissent ans les 16 de basse pointe
en 48 challenge en 74
on va arriver en 1963 la cgtm qui se
démarque de ce mouvement cégétiste la
cgt qui voit le jour avec pour commencer
certain victor lamont alors bien entendu
alors l'acidité m dès sa création en vue
dans l'amour et la mire la moyenne 36 je
disais tout à l'heure que jules monnerot
a été un petit peu le détonateur en 19
ans rompant avec les socialistes
et à ce moment là une coalition va se
faire entre bissol la môme en eau etc et
ils vont donner naissance à l'union qui
va être lyon cgt et qui va adhérer
immédiatement la cgt française et tout
cela va donner une espèce de pulsion une
organisation des combats et vous avez
raison de signaler
l'un des fers de lance du mouvement
ouvrier à l'époque c'était les ouvriers
agricoles faut savoir que depuis
trente-six depuis 1900 ils ont commencé
eux depuis avant 1900 depuis l'abolition
de l'esclavagé c'était l'organisation
économique d'être une organisation qui
te contrat à l'école bien entendu les
mettait en avant dans les luttes et ils
ont parfaitement conduit à aller faire
pour la défendre milteau rieuse alors la
cgtm qui voit naissance début juin 1963
avec trois sont des terres génère on a
parlé de victoire lamont il y a eu fini
baer du fel est actuellement ghislaine
jour charneau aujourd'hui être cégétiste
c'est très difficile lorsqu'on voit
cette faible mobilisation des salariés
de l'individualisme à cause des méfaits
de la mondialisation pape en espagne
pape absolument il faut voir que le
contrat de travail du salarié a
considérablement évolué il faut voir il
travaille à travers cette situation de
recul
le poids du chômage il faut voir que
aujourd'hui la fragilisation du contrat
de travail avec les emplois aidés parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de sites l'emploi etc
mais quinze mille emplois aidés c'est à
dire des salariés qui n'ont pas d'avenir
des salariés qui ne lesquels il faut pas
compter pour le combat dans la mesure où
justement ils n'ont aucune sécurité de
l'emploi ils sont tenus ils sont tenus
par le diktat du patronat avec la
complicité du gouvernement selon vos
termes ils sont tenus mais il ya une
exploitation féroce
il ya une exploitation de ces
travailleurs qui est considérable les
salariés qui n'ont pas cette possibilité
de s'organiser de ce parce que tu es
déjà la capacité de se défendre
qui fait qu'un salarié peut se mettre
debout devant son employeur et lui
réclamer ses droits et bien lorsqu'on a
un contrat de travail précaires est-ce
que l'on capacité de le faire non on
append on n'a pas ces moyens là et cette
précarisation de l'emploi justement déjà
en premier lieu fragilise le contrat de
travail est fragile nous rendre lequel
on est merci d'avoir été avec nous louis
maugée de la commission exécutive de la
cgt me rappelle qu' aujourd'hui s'ouvre
tout une cycle tout cycle de
commémoration vous avez notamment cité
la venue de monsieur martinez de son été
en général de la suite il y aura
d'autres délégations de guadeloupe
guyane de mayotte en présence en
martinique et puis vous allez tourner un
peu partout cet âne sept maris plutôt
saint-pierre fort de france merci
d'avoir été avec nous et on vous suivra
pendant ses 80 ans du mouvement
cégétiste à la martinique ainsi de nous
avons invité
c'était son caddie avec menton